mais merci à eric merci à vous tous et à
vous tous d'être venus nombreux comme
cela a été dit guillaume larrivé roger
karoutchi et moi même avons à la demande
du président et d'eric organisé cette
demi-journée finalement sur un sujet qui
s'inscrit dans une actualité extrêmement
prégnante
chacun a bien pu le constater c'est une
d'enfoncer une porte ouverte que de dire
cela
il n'empêche que c'est un sujet majeur
nous le savons tous sujets auxquels nous
avons souhaité que nous avons souhaité
organes prêté en tous les cas d'une
manière assez simple autour de trois
tables rondes qui seront des tables
rondes d'abord consacré au constat
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui
comment interpréter la situation
d'aujourd'hui
elle sera animée ces tables rondes donc
par par guillaume larrivé avec des
invités pierre lellouche natacha
bouchart michèle tribalat pascal
perrineau nadia amour et patrick
stefanini la deuxième table ronde aura
pour objectif l animé par roger
karoutchi de débattre sur ce que font
les autres états européens
quelles sont leurs politiques sur cette
matière
quel est le retour d'expérience pouvons
nous en tirer pour nous-mêmes évidemment
et pour une politique de demain et puis
enfin la dernière table ronde c'est
quelle évolution et quelles ruptures
nécessaires pour redonner un autre pays
le droit de choisir ce qu'ils souhaitent
accueillir en france car la question est
bien celle ci aujourd'hui l'objet de ce
séminaire c'est de réfléchir à quelle
politique d'immigration pour notre pays
bien sûr il ya des enjeux nationaux il
ya aussi un contexte international
extrêmement fort et nous souhaitons de
ce fait débattre de tout cela il y a
beaucoup d'idées beaucoup de sujets
abordés évidemment la politique de
l'asile
qui est une politique spécifique bien
sûr compte tenu du fait qu'il faut
protéger des gens qui sont poursuivies
dans leur pays et qui risquent leur vie
dans leur pays d'origine
mais comment quel volume
combien avec quels outils comment on
traite la situation d'aujourd'hui il ya
la politique d'immigration régulière
qu'il faut repenser et que nous
souhaitons pouvoir définir avec des
propositions très concrètes on veut pas
les évoquer maintenant ce sera l'objet
de nos discussions et là c'est
régulièrement arriver une politique
d'immigration choisie avec deux axes
principaux que nous connaissons bien
qu'ils aient la refonte des notions du
regroupement familial bien évidemment la
question de la santé de ce qu'on appelle
l'aide médicale d'état notamment ce ne
sont pas les seuls sujets en la matière
il ya aussi l'obtention de certains
titres de séjour il ya aussi évidemment
la question des visas tout ce qui est
politique régulière simplement peut-être
enfin terminée sur le troisième sujet
est majeur qui est celui de la politique
de l'immigration irrégulière laquelle
constitue un enjeu absolument
fondamentale quel est notre véritable
quelles sont nos véritables moyens
d'agir sur l'éloignement de ceux qui
sont en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire
ce n'est pas simplement de dire il faut
qu'ils repartent bien sûr qu'il le faut
mais nous avons des obstacles juridiques
qui a franchi nous avons des obstacles
de toute nature qui donc il faudra bien
évoqué qu'il reviendrait été mais ça
reste un sujet majeur
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire au
début de cette réunion peu de gens
évidemment ici me connaissent moi je
suis sénateur du rhône
donc je sais à peu près comment on vit
comme en ile-de-france la pression
migratoire sur notre département et j'ai
été d'ailleurs sur la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy le rapporteur du tout
les textes immigration au sénat et
d'asile et je suis en ce moment en
charge était en charge de l'asile au
sénat je suis en charge du droit des
étrangers également au sénat en ce
moment donc c'est dire que c'est un
sujet qui nous préoccupe vraiment et qui
est le sujet majeur pour nous voilà moi
j'ai été beaucoup trop long sur ce que
je voulais vous dire via une
contribution aussi les sénateurs ont
travaillé avec les collègues en interne
sur des propositions qui vont contribuer
au travail de notre mouvement politique
à la préparation de ce que l'on souhaite
soumettre à nos à nos adhérents et dans
ce grand moment de concertation de
débats et de préparation du travail
c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous a
semblé utile de faire en interne au
cedar voilà merci à tous de votre
attention je laisse la parole tout de
suite à guillaume pour évidemment le
fait qu'ils interviennent et puis
engager tout de suite
ensuite la première table ronde bercy